herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
sie wollten die Titanic sehen ganz aus
der Nähe am Meeresgrund des Nordatlantik
in einer Tiefe von
3.800 Metern da auf dem Weg zur Titanic
da ist der Kontakt ab zu ihrem Tauchboot
seit Sonntagabend gilt dieses Boots die
Zeiten gelten die fünf Abenteurer als
verschollen nun suchen Rettungskräfte in
Nordatlantik vor der kanadischen Küste
mit allem was sie haben nach den
Vermissten seit heute im Einsatz sogar
ein kanadisches See Aufklärungsflugzeug
Mann habe inzwischen mehr als 26.000
Quadratmeter Fläche abgesucht doch
gefunden haben sie bisher nicht ob
dieses Tauchboot auf dem Meeresgrund in
3800 m Tiefe liegt oder ob es vielleicht
gestiegen ist unerkannt unentdeckt an
der Meeresoberfläche treibt das weiß
keiner nur eines ist klar die Luft an
Bord dieses tauchboots die reicht wohl
maximal bis
Donnerstag es ist insofern ein
dramatischer Wettlauf mit gegen die Zeit
wir wollen heute sprechen mit meiner
Kollegin Brigitte Saar die selbst schon
in einem Tauchboot zum Wrack der Titanic
runtergegangen runtergetaucht ist und
die sogar zwei der fünf Menschen an Bord
der Titan kennt wir wollen gleich auch
direkt live von unserem Korrespondenten
Johannes Hano hören wie der Stand der
Dinge ist wie die Suche vorankommt wir
wollen mit Ihnen sprechen natürlich auch
über eure Fragen und Kommentare also
einfach her damit dann können wir mit
unseren beiden Gesprächspartnern darüber
reden bevor wir jetzt mit Johannes
johanno in New York sprechen kurz
zusammengefasst die derzeitige Lage
knapp 7 m lang und 10 Tonnen schwer
vermisst im Nordatlantik zwischen Kanada
und den USA es ist die Suche nach der
Nadel im Heuhaufen am Sonntag war das
Tauchboot der Firma Ocean Gate
expeditions mit fünf Menschen an Bord
auf dem Weg zum wagt der Titanic
darunter ein Wissenschaftler und drei
Touristen aus Großbritannien und
Pakistan die 250.000
$ für den Tauchgang bezahlt haben nach
einer Stunde und 45 Minuten bricht der
Kontakt zum Begleitschiff ab die
Rettungsmission schwierig
etwa 1.500 km östlich von Cape Cott in
einer Wassertiefe von knapp 4000 Metern
es ist eine sehr weit abgelegene Gegend
und es ist eine große Herausforderung
dort eine Suche durchzuführen
für 96 Stunden hat das Tauchboot
Sauerstoff an Bord und so bleibt den
Retter nicht viel Zeit das Boot
aufzuspüren und im Notfall auch zu heben
es ist ein Rennen gegen die Zeit
unsere Einsatzkräfte haben die Fähigkeit
visuelle als auch Radar suchen
durchzuführen und die Kanadier können so
narbojen abwerfen
bisher aber ist völlig unklar wo sich
das Tauchboot befindet ob in 3800 Metern
tiefer auf dem Meeresgrund oder bis
irgendwo an der Oberfläche treibt das
wäre das beste Szenario denn der
Sauerstoff an Bord geht so Nike
und jetzt ist er uns zugeschaltet
Johannes Hano er ist in New York genau
an dem Pia an dem 1912 die Titanic hätte
festmachen sollen an dem Pia an dem sie
aber nie angekommen ist Johannes wie ist
denn jetzt bei der Suche nach diesem
Titanic Tauchboot der Titan der Stand
der Dinge gibt es irgendwelche
Neuigkeiten
also es gab gerade eine Pressekonferenz
in Boston beim Kommando der
amerikanischen Küstenwache dort oben und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen nachdem was
wir da gehört haben bin ich nicht
besonders optimistisch dass diese
Rettungsaktion erfolgreich sein wird was
man da gesagt ist man hat bisher 26.000
Quadratkilometer abgesucht und hat
bisher nichts gefunden an der Oberfläche
man hat setzt so nabuieren ein die tief
ins Wasser reingehen können auch da ist
man noch nicht fündig geworden es man
wird jetzt wohl auch einsetzen ein
ferngesteuertes Mini U-Boot das dann auf
dem Grund suchen soll aber das hört sich
nicht danach an dass das im Moment also
man hat überhaupt keine Hinweise darauf
wo dieses Brot sein soll und man hat
noch überhaupt keine Idee wo man
weitersuchen kann das ganze gestaltet
sich sehr schwierig es wurde auch gesagt
dass man den Mond besser kennt als den
Ocean ground also den den Meeresboden
und man weiß gar nicht wo man so richtig
suchen soll so hört sich das jedenfalls
ein bisschen an auf der anderen Seite
sagt man selbst wenn man das findet
besteht die große Sorge dass man nicht
rechtzeitig dieses Boot dann auch heben
kann dass man nicht daran kommen kann
man hat zwar jetzt alles in Bewegung
gesetzt um dieses Boot um das Gerät an
den Ort zu bringen aber wir haben das ja
schon gehört dass es 1500 Kilometer von
amerikanischen Küste entfernt die
US-Küstenwache oder die Amerikaner haben
ein Rettungsboot für U-Boote das wurde
aber nicht gesagt wo das gerade ist und
selbst wenn es in der Nähe wäre fährt es
nur sehr sehr langsam also ob das dann
auch rechtzeitig ankäme ist die große
Frage auf die Frage von Reportern hat
der Kommandeur dort gesagt man müssen
schauen wo das Boot genau ist auf
welcher Tiefe ist es auf dem Meeresgrund
schwebt es irgendwo in der Mitte weil
kein Ballast hätte abwerfen können oder
treibt es in der oberflächlich und
danach würde man dann entscheiden wie
man rettet aber wie gesagt das hörte
sich alles nicht besonders viel
versprechen dann Johannes wovon geht man
denn eigentlich aus dass dieses
Tauchboot nachdem der Kontakt
abgebrochen ist weiter gesund ist also
gegebenenfalls am Meeresgrund auf 3800
Metern liegt oder ob es vielleicht die
Chance gibt oder ist es so dass es
Ballast abgeworfen hat hochgegangen ist
an der Oberfläche ist und einfach nur
noch nicht auf diesen großen
Nordatlantik entdeckt worden ist
also beide Optionen werden hier gerade
durchgespielt man hat einerseits
Flugzeuge im Einsatz die großflächig den
Nordatlantik an der Oberfläche absuchen
man hat aber bislang noch nichts
gefunden und dann hat man eben mit so
einer Bojen das muss man sich auch klar
machen man kann nicht mit Radar in den
Grund gehen beim großflächig sondern man
muss so nabuieren werfen und da hofft
man jetzt falls das Brot gesunken sein
sollte dass die Menschen an Bord noch am
Leben sind und dass sie vielleicht
Geräusche machen können die von den
Sonar Bojen aufgenommen werden und dass
man dann einen Hinweis bekommt in welche
Richtung man weitersuchen muss aber das
ist sehr viel IFS sozusagen also sehr
viel wenn dann wenn dann so ganz genau
weiß man das nicht man nimmt im Moment
noch alle Optionen war man sucht auf
allen Ebenen was macht die Suche so
schwierig das ist ja modernste Technik
so nah Bojen äh Flugzeuge mit so nah
aber
du sagst ja auch man kennt den Boden den
Meeresgrund gar nicht so gut soweit ich
verstanden habe liegt die Titanic sogar
in einem Graben jetzt bin ich kein
Techniker mach das das für das so nah
dann auch schwieriger überhaupt diesen
Boden so zu scannen dass man irgendwie
bei Gräben und Riffen unter Wasser dann
überhaupt ebenso ein kleines äh
Tauchboot wie die Zeiten finden kann
also ganz ehrlich da bin ich kein
Experte und ich glaube dass die Brigitte
sah dir ja gleich auch noch hier habt
dass die euch da sehr viel besser
Auskunft geben kann das ist die Expertin
ich habe vorhin mal mit ihr gesprochen
bin ziemlich beeindruckt von ihren
Kenntnissen was wir wissen ist dass der
Boden sehr dass man nicht genau weiß wie
das alles da unten aussieht dass man
nicht genau was ist eine Riesenfläche
die man absuchen muss und dass man nicht
genau weiß welche Geräte dort wirklich
funktionieren ähm Suchgerät und man wie
gesagt man hat jetzt einen einen einen
ferngesteuertes Mini U-Boot dass man
dann da runterfahren kann und um genau
auf die Meeresboden abzusuchen aber die
Fläche ist einfach gigantisch groß das
ist der Nordatlantik das ist irgendwie
ungefähr umrechnen 400 das sind ungefähr
1000 km von der kanadischen Küste und
1500 km von amerikanischen Küste
entfernt in einem riesigen Gebiet in dem
es auch im Moment nicht besonders viel
Schiff Verkehr gibt also die Suche ist
wirklich die Stecknadel im Heuhaufen
dazu finden das ist wahnsinnig komplex
und wahnsinnig kompliziert das hat man
auch gerade auf dieser Pressekonferenz
noch mal betont das ist ungeheuer
schwierig ist ein so großes Gebiet
wirklich
später genau das Zentimeter genau
abzusuchen um dann ein so kleines Boot
das ist ja nur zehn Meter leide sechs
Meter 70 lang so ein kleines Bode auf
dieser Riesenfläche zu finden das ist
wahnsinnig Komplex ja wir sehen ja
gerade auch noch mal die Karte und sehen
sehr deutlich das was du gesagt hast
erstens einmal auch die Entfernung von
Land von der nächstgelegenen Küste aber
das andere ist ja eben auch die große
Tiefe du hast ja schon angeschnitten es
gibt ja nicht mal eben um die Ecke und
überall jede Menge U-Boote die eine
solche Tiefe erreichen können wir können
uns das ja auch mal anschauen das ist da
ja große Unterschiede gibt und eben auch
Grenzen gibt denn ähm die meisten
militärischen U-Boote erreichende
Tauchtiefe von 500 bis 600 Metern einige
schaffen es eventuell auch etwas tiefer
bis 1000 aber dann ist auch für das
beste Marine U-Boot Schluss die Titanic
liegt jedoch nicht in tausend sondern
Tiefe von 3800 m das ist also insofern
für jedes Militär U-Boot oder für kein
Militär U-Boot
erreichbar also die US Navy oder die
kanadische Marine kann also nicht ein
militärisches U-Boot hinstecken
spezielle Tiefsee U-Boote kommen
deutlich tiefer da gibt es Unterseeboote
die darauf spezialisiert sind diesen
deutlich höheren Druck der Tiefsee Stand
zu halten eines der bekanntesten
tiefseeu-boote ist die Alvin sie schafft
6.500 Meter und die Triest das ist noch
das Besondere U-Boot das ist geschafft
hat
1960 das war das erste U-Boot der Welt
das 1960 im Marianengraben mit rund
10.910 m Tiefe also fast 11 km Tiefe das
sogenannte Challenger Tief erreicht hat
eine der tiefsten Stellen des Weltmeeres
und anschließend auch wieder auftauchte
aber das zeigt eben das ist so gut wie
kaum Boote gibt Tauchboote gibt die mal
eben da hin können äußerst knifflig ähm
Johannes das Bergen du hast es ja gerade
ein ganz großer eine ganz große
Fragezeichen ja auch angesprochen selbst
wenn man findet wie sieht es mit der
Bergung aus jetzt hast du auch Erfahrung
und es gibt ja auch viele Beispiele
dafür dass das Bergen eines
Schiffswracks selbst wenn man es
gefunden hat auch nicht gerade einfach
ist ne
nein das ist ungeheuer schwierig es ist
mal in den 60er Jahren und 1968 ist ein
russisches Atom U-Boot vor der
amerikanischen Küste im Pazifik gesunken
wie man dieses U-Boot retten kann die
Amerikaner hat vor allem die CIA wollte
unbedingt dieses U-Boot haben um die
russische Technologie dort aufzuspüren
und man hat sage und schreibe sechs
Jahre gebraucht um dieses U-Boot zu
heben das lag damals ich glaube in 5000
Meter Tiefe man hat extra ein Boot
gebaut das hat um es geheim zu halten
war dass der amerikanische Milliardär
Howard Judith der hat dieses Boot gebaut
ist dann rausgefahren man hat es
tatsächlich geschafft wenn eine
speziellen Vorrichtung greifvorrichtung
so tief runterzukommen und beim Heben
dieses botes ist dieses russische U-Boot
dann aber auseinandergebrochen das macht
noch einmal klar was für ein enormer
Aufwand das ist in einer solchen Tiefe
überhaupt eine solche Operation
durchzuführen was man jetzt hofft ist
dass man möglicherweise irgendwie an
dieses U-Boot falls man ist den findet
herankommt dass man es alleine lange
Leine legen kann und dann langsam
hochziehen kann man muss ja auch
aufpassen glaube ich was den Druck
angeht man weiß nicht wie kaputt dieses
Boot ist also das wird selbst wenn man
es findet auf dem Meeresgrund eine
enorme schwierige Operation und ob man
das in den 41 Stunden jetzt noch schafft
in denen der Sauerstoff ausreicht das
ist doch sehr unwahrscheinlich glaube
ich jedenfalls also dann sagen wir ein
großes Dankeschön Johannes Hano eine
Suche mit vielen Fragezeichen und du
hast es schon gesagt um optimistisch zu
sein braucht man schon eine ganze ganze
Menge Hoffnung vielen Dank Johannes Hano
und du wirst uns natürlich auch
weiterhin auf dem laufenden halten danke
nach New York wie gesagt fünf Menschen
haben das Abenteuer gestartet in
3800 m Tiefe zu tauchen sind ein großes
Risiko eingegangen um die Titanic zu
sehen und man könnte fragen warum die
Titanic ist ja nicht irgendein Schiff
sie kann Mythos
1912 ist die Titanic das größte Schiff
der Welt ein Ozeanriese der als
unsinkbark gilt auf ihrer historischen
Jungfernfahrt von England nach New York
sind mehr als 2000 Menschen an Bord am
14 April flügt sie mit rund 21 Knoten
durch den Nordatlantik und kollidiert
mit einem Eisberg die Titanic zerbricht
und singt fast 1500 Menschen sterben
beim Untergang des Kreuzfahrtschiffs
seitdem liegt sie am Grund des eiskalten
Nordatlantiks und fasziniert die
Menschen mit ihrer Geschichte das fragt
des Luxus dann fast wird erst 1985
entdeckt in rund 3800 m Tiefe in einem
Graben in völliger Dunkelheit rund 700
km vor der Küste Neufundlands
metallfressende Bakterien nagen an den
Überresten und so erwarten einige
Experten dass das Schiff in wenigen
Jahrzehnten vollständig verschwunden
sein könnte und auch deshalb nutzen
viele die Zeit reisen Seite Entdeckung
des W Racks immer wieder dorthin nicht
nur Forscher sondern auch Touristen
ja und eine dieser Menschen die es so
runtergezogen hat zur Titanic weil sie
fasziniert sind das ist meine Kollegin
Brigitte Sasi interessiert sich seitdem
13 lebensjahr für die Titanic für das
Schicksal der Titanic und ist in
mehreren Titanic Vereinen und
festgehalten ist eben selbst zum Wrack
schon runtergetaucht Brigitte vielen
vielen Dank dass wir mit dir reden
können und deine Erfahrung eben auch
nutzen können erzähl einfach mal wie war
das und wie ist das nach so einem Wrack
in diese unendliche Tiefe runter zu
tauchen
es ist hauptsächlich erstmal eng also
diese Kapseln sind außen ein paar Meter
lang und innen drin sozusagen diese
überlebenssphäre in der man da unterwegs
ist die ist im Idealfall ist die
zweieinhalb mal ein Meter fünfzig jetzt
zum Beispiel bei der Titan bei mir waren
es eine Kugel zwei Meter 10 im
Durchmesser und da steckt man mit
mehreren Menschen drin also man muss
sich da schon also man ist sich schon
bewusst das ist ein Abenteuer und das
ist sehr ungewöhnlich und damit muss man
auch irgendwie im Kopf klar kommen und
dann gibt's einen langen Weg nach unten
der dauert so zweieinhalb drei Stunden
bis man überhaupt mal am Meeresboden ist
und dann kommt aber im Prinzip das große
spannende Abenteuer und dann vergisst
man auch letztendlich alles um sich rum
die Enge und die unbequem halt es gibt
zum Beispiel in meiner Tauchkapsel gab
es keine Toilette also auch das muss man
irgendwie anders hinkriegen und anders
lösen aber wenn man dann da ist und man
sieht dieses weltberühmte Wrack und man
sieht mit eigenen Augen die Brücke und
den Buch und die Anker dann ist es
natürlich großes Abenteuer und was man
da eigentlich wie extrem man unterwegs
war das wird einem oft erst im
Nachhinein klar wenn man wieder oben ist
und man noch mit einem klar ist wie tief
man da unten war wie verletzlich man da
unten auch ist weil Hannes hanna hat ja
auch schon gesagt da kann einem niemand
groß helfen da muss man sich wenn was
passiert zunächst versuchen selbst zu
helfen
jetzt aber du hast es ja beschrieben es
ist eine verdammt riskante Sache wird
das denn irgendwie festgelegt dass der
Veranstalter dann sagt naja es ist ein
bisschen was anderes als eine
Planwagenfahrt durch die Weinberge nach
dem Motto unterschreiben Sie mal hier
dass wir nicht die Verantwortung
übernehmen ja genau das also ich kenne
keine Expedition zum Praktik der Titanic
wo es vorher nicht einen mehrseitigen
Vertrag gab mit haftungsausschlüssen da
geht es zum einen um Geld was passiert
wenn man die Titanic nicht erreicht ist
dann die geleistete Zahlung weg oder
nicht und da gibt's aber auch einen
Passus wo dann eben drin steht dies ist
ein hoch riskantes Unternehmen wir
haften für gar nichts also bei mir war
dieser Satz drin so vierter fünfter
Absatz in case of your death also im
Falle ihres Todes und dann der Hinweis
wenn wir sie nicht vorsätzlich sozusagen
umbringen dann gibt es keine Haftung und
ich weiß von den Verträgen aus den
aktuellen Tauchgängen das ist da auch so
ist also die Leute müssen das vorher
unterschreiben und ich gebe auch zu dass
auch ich erstmal
20 Minuten um den Küchentisch rum
getigert bin und mir überlegt habe ob
ich denn das jetzt wirklich mache weil
vor diesem Vertrag war mir die
Lebensgefahr natürlich auch so nicht
bewusst
jetzt gibt es doch schon viele Fragen
die du vielleicht ja eben beantworten
kannst wie läuft so ein Tauchgang ab
moin moin moin 90 schreibe über Youtube
von welchen Temperaturen ist zum
Beispiel in so einem Tauchboot
auszugehen
und was sagt der Hersteller gibt es denn
Materialprobleme oder wie läuft das
ganze ab wenn man vor allen Dingen eben
in diese Tiefe geht und dieser Druck das
wissen wir ja alle oder wer taucht weiß
es ganz besonders in der Pferdes
irgendwie tiefer man geht der Druck wird
immer höher und in 3800 m Tiefe ist der
Druck enorm wie erlebt man das was ist
da was hinter alles diese Besonderheiten
also die Temperatur wird von ganz warm
geht runter zu ganz kalt wenn man oben
an Bord einsteigt dann ist die Kapsel ja
möglicherweise schon ein paar Stunden an
Deck gestanden ist also quasi von der
von der Sonne aufgewärmt du gehst reine
schwitzt erst mal dann wird die Kapsel
verschlossen geht ins Wasser man taucht
und dann gibt es gibt keine Klimaanlage
es gibt keine Heizung da drin was würde
alles Energie brauchen und man hat ja
nur seine Batterien und dann wird es so
Stück für Stück kälter das Wasser am
Wrack ist so bei 2 Grad plus in etwa und
das heißt man wird immer es wird immer
kühler man sieht mehr Sachen an dadurch
dass man mehr Sachen anzieht kann man
natürlich die Kapsel selber auch nicht
mehr sozusagen mit bio-wärme beheizen
und zum Schluss saßen wir da in so
thermoanzügen das ist das eine was das
Material angeht die Tauchkapsel die da
gerade unten ist ist ein wenig
ungewöhnlich ist ein Pionier sozusagen
was die Ingenieursarbeit angeht weil es
gab schon andere tauchkapseln mit der
man zur Titanic tauchen konnte die waren
alle aus Metall aus Titan aus
Nickelstahl und waren als Kugel
konzipiert und diese Tauchkapsel ist
jetzt die erste mit einer derartigen
tiefen
Reichweite die im Prinzip ein Zylinder
ist aus Carbonfasern natürlich ist es
jetzt eigentlich schon die dritte
Expedition das heißt man hat Ex man hat
Daten man hat Erfahrungen mit dieser
Kapsel schon gehabt aber bei weitem
nicht so viele Erfahrungen wie mit
diesen anderen Kapseln die ein sehr
bewährtes System einfach hatten einen
Eindruck Körper eine Kugel leitet auch
den Druck gut ab das war bewährt
sozusagen und ob jetzt das Material in
diesen Unfall wenn es denn einer ist mit
rein spielt oder nicht das weiß man
einfach noch nicht das muss man abwarten
wir haben jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
die Animation dieser Titan dieses
tauchbos gesehen da blinkt das kleine
Licht passt hier zu der Frage
die hier gestellt wird von Asus Striker
x haben solche Dinger denn keinen
Peilsender ein Notsender sowas muss doch
jede Rest Rettungsweste haben schreibt
er insofern einfach die Frage wir haben
ja von Johannes gerade beschrieben
bekommen die schwierig die Suche ist man
versucht mit so nah das ganze Ding zu
orten gibt's nicht umgekehrt eigentlich
irgendeine Vorrichtung das in deinem
Fall damals so diese Kugel oder jetzt
hier eben diese Titan dass ein Signal
ausgesendet wird während dieses
Tauchgangs
also natürlich gibt es Kommunikation
aber die ist schwierig also das ist
anders wie in der Oberfläche kann man
nicht einfach gesprochene Funksprüche
austauschen diese also die Wassersäule
ist ganz schwer zu nutzen zum Übertragen
von Signalen deswegen sind die auch im
Prinzip nur schriftlich miteinander
verbunden also die die Zeiten kann wie
so eine Art digitaler Maus Code kann die
Daten verschicken Text verschicken und
der kann dann oben empfangen und wieder
zusammengesetzt werden also mal kurz an
anrufen oder Notsignal absetzen das geht
schon mal nicht einfach hier tiefer
diese diese Tauchkapsel kommt desto
schwieriger ist die Kommunikation mit
nach oben das ist ja letztendlich bei
den Flugzeugabstürzen auch so dass man
erst ziemlich genau wissen muss wo man
sucht und teilweise auch schon im Wasser
sein muss bevor man z.B die Funksignale
der Black Box findet deswegen würde
dieses Signal vermutlich an der Stelle
wo sie sich jetzt befindet auch gar
nicht so viel bringen und im Moment
scheint ja auch oder wenn es ein
Kommunikationsproblem gibt ist es
naheliegend dass es möglicherweise auch
ein Energieproblem gab und dann könnte
man auch dieses Notsignal möglicherweise
einfach gar nicht absetzen weil man ja
keinen Strom mehr hat oder weil die
Batterien irgendwie schlecht
funktionieren
dass es schwierig also aber ich glaube
es hat keiner darüber nachgedacht eine
Art Black Box mit Funke irgendwo ja
unterzubringen weil man ja einfach immer
davon ausgehen dass diese Kapsel am
Stück und im Takt ist anders als z.B bei
einem Flugzeugabsturz wo man ja am
schlimmsten Fall Teile finden muss aber
der scheint das beschäftigt eben viele
moin moin schreibt auch noch mal hier
als nächste Frage gab es denn ein
Notsignal andere Medien berichten
darüber wir haben telefoniert du hast
noch mal recherchiert weil das durch die
Medien tatsächlich geistert ist gegangen
ist so heute am Nachmittag hast du dann
auch was rausbekommen
also das ist nicht bestätigt und ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das nicht quasi eine
Fehlübersetzung ist die die Aussage es
hätte ein Signal gegeben bevor man
Kontakt verloren hätte stammt von einem
Wissenschaftler aus England der in
seiner ursprünglichen Aussage selbst
sagt das ist aus zweiter Hand und jetzt
ist die Frage meint er dieses letzte
regelmäßige Standards Signal das vor dem
kommunikationsabriss im rausgegangen ist
oder meint er tatsächlich an eine Art
Notruf also ein Sondersignal in dem
wirklich verschlüsselt die Botschaft ist
Hilfe hier läuft was schief das ist
nicht bestätigt und ich glaube eher dass
irgendwo ein Zitat übersetzt noch mal
zitiert noch mal übersetzt wurde und
dass dieser Bezug auf das letzte Signal
vor dem Signal Abriss inzwischen als
Notsignal quasi tituliert wurde also es
hat bisher keiner bestätigt dass es
wirklich eine aktive Botschaft von von
dieser Kapsel gab das ist Probleme gibt
und die war ja auch schon ziemlich weit
unten also
die die letzte Botschaft kam eine Stunde
45 nach dem Beginn dieser Tauchfahrt und
die nächste hätte also dann im Prinzip
bei zwei Stunden kommen müssen nach
einer Viertelstunde und wenn auf so
einem normalen standardtauchgang zur
Titanic dürfte die Kapsel da schon so in
also auf jeden Fall jenseits von 2000
Meter Tiefe sein vermutlich eher über
3000 Meter Tiefe und gar nicht mehr so
weit vom Rack entfernt und da wäre diese
Kommunikation einfach extrem schwierig
das fraglich ist ob ein Signal da bis
nach oben durchkommt überhaupt empfangen
werden kann also schon mal sehr sehr
interessant weil du aus deiner Erfahrung
eben weißt dass man eben in diesen eine
Stunde 45 Minuten in dieser Zeit schon
in eine große Tiefe doch bei so einem
Tauchgang hinab kommt jetzt gibt es auch
noch eine technische Frage die halt sehr
interessant ist es wird von Experten
erklärt selbst wenn es so sein sollte
dass dieses Tauchboot Ballast abwirft
und vielleicht von alleine an die
Oberfläche kommt selbst dann ist noch
nicht die Rettung abgeschlossen weil die
Menschen diese dieses Boot nicht von
innen öffnen können erklär uns das mal
man würde ja eigentlich meinen ich sag
mal der Taucher der ist irgendwie
schafft an die Oberfläche zu kommen ich
war der kann wieder Luft schnappen der
kann atmen aber was ist jetzt das
Besondere hier bei diesem Tauchboot der
Titan genau also man muss mit diesen
drei Komponenten man hat diese Röhre in
der Mitte und dann links und rechts von
dieser Röhre hat man so Halbkugel die
das abschließen muss man ja insgesamt
einen Druckkörper Herstellen der der
funktioniert der dicht hält bei diesen
enormen Druckverhältnis Antrag also am
Wrack reden wir bei
400 Tonnen pro Quadratzentimeter
Oberfläche das ist echt viel das
bedeutet dass man normalerweise an der
Oberfläche in dieses in diese
Tauchkapsel einsteigt und dann wird
diese letzte Halbschale sozusagen der
der Front Dom wird dann von Essen mit
langen Schrauben drauf geschraubt der
ist da fix das ist keine Türklinke die
man kurz von innen aufmachen kann ich
glaube das ist auch ein Szenario dass
man so bisher nicht gedacht hatte das
heißt wenn diese Titan tatsächlich
unversehrt wäre und es schafft an die
Meeresoberfläche zu kommen dann kann man
eben nicht die Luke aufmachen und
signalraketen abschießen oder sonst was
oder mal Lüften sage ich jetzt einfach
mal weil das große kritische Thema ist
ja tatsächlich die lebensrettenden
Systeme wie lange die noch laufen
sondern man muss diese Kapsel finden und
die sitzen da drin und sind drauf
angewiesen dass sie daraus befreit
werden das von außen geöffnet wird und
dafür müssen sie eben gefunden werden
also und wenn wir noch mal sehen wie
groß der Nordatlantik ist wie weit die
Entfernung ist von der Küste wäre es
eben ja wünschenswert dass er in die
Oberfläche kommen aber auch dann machst
du deutlich ist es ein Wettlauf gegen
die Zeit denn selbst wenn die Zeiten an
der Oberfläche ist ist es weiterhin ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit dass diese
dieses Tauchboot auch gefunden wird
damit eben diese Kapsel aufgemacht wird
jetzt gibt es viele viele Fragen die die
User stellen Equinox über Youtube fragt
weil du das vielleicht eben
angeschnitten hast auch mit der Toilette
die es nicht gibt er fragt hat das Ding
eigentlich eine Toilette begamen sie
denn eigentlich auch hygienische
Probleme wenn man so lange da unten ist
jetzt musst du mal erklären wie ich das
ganze denn funktioniert wenn in deinem
Fall drei Leute oder hier in diesem Fall
fünf Leute doch mehrere Stunden am Tage
an Bord einer solchen Kapsel oder eines
solchen Tauchboot sind
also ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen
grundsätzlich ist dass das geringste
Problem dass sie jetzt haben aber wenn
man einfach mal rein sachlich
beantworten möchte es gibt dort so eine
Art kleine Campingtoilette sage ich
jetzt mal wo man seine Notdurft schon
verrichten kann wo man notfalls dann
auch mal die notduft Nummer zwei
verrichten könnte wenn man jetzt für
mehrere Tage in dieser Kapsel gefangen
ist ähm also das geht das ist nicht sehr
bequem man ist ja immer noch in einer
kleinen Röhre bei der Zeiten in dem Fall
mit vier anderen Menschen aber also
daran würde es nicht scheitern es gibt
dort ist sogar einen kleinen Vorhang so
dass man wenn man wirklich mal müsste um
optisch getrennt von den Mitreisenden
ähm Platz nehmen könnte
es aber wie gesagt es ist garantiert
nicht das Problem wenn also diese fünf
Menschen da noch ansonsten weitgehend
gesund in dieser Kapsel festhängen wird
daran nicht scheitern
die Luft der Sauerstoff das eben das
Hauptproblem alone Wolf schreibt ihr
gefragt über Youtube gibt es denn
eigentlich auch Trinkwasser da an Bord
wie sieht's das aus wird man mit
Sicherheit Vorräte haben aber ob die
jetzt knapp werden und so weiter ist
glaube ich auch zweitrangig wie siehst
du das Brigitte ja also die haben
sicherlich was zu trinken mitgenommen
weil auch auf einem normalen Tauchgang
der irgendwo so im Bereich zehn Stunden
plus minus dauert kriegt man ja
irgendwann mal irgendwie Durst oder
Hunger also man kann auch ein Snack
mitnehmen ich habe damals auch wir
hatten Tee dabei wir hatten ein paar
Schokoriegel dabei das geht das kann man
sicherlich wenn man merkt jetzt wird es
eng auch ein Stück weit Strecken weil
diese
dieser dieser
informationsabriss dieser dieser
signalabriss der fand ja sehr früh an
diesen Tag an dieser Mission statt im
Prinzip schon nach zwei Stunden
vermutlich etwas da kann man sich schon
noch einen teilen das ist also nicht das
große Problem das große Problem sind
wirklich die die lebenserhaltenden
Systeme der Sauerstoff insbesondere bzw
das sind zwei Komponenten sie brauchen
Sauerstoff und auf der anderen Seite
gibt es Filter dieses Kohlendioxid
wieder aus der Atemluft dieser Kapsel
rausholen müssen und da sind eben nicht
ganz klar für wie viel Stunden es reicht
diese 96 Stunden die da immer angegeben
werden sind im Prinzip die Zahl die
technische berechnete Zahl für die
Reserve die sie haben das beinhaltet
nicht den Sauerstoff den sie sowieso an
Bord hatten und die Filter für die
normale Expedition da gibt es also quasi
einen separaten Tank den man dann
aktivieren kann wenn es eng wird das
heißt auf die 96 Stunden
technisch berechnete Reserve kommt
zusätzlich noch die Luft die Filter die
Kapazität die sie sowieso standardmäßig
für diese Mission an Bord hatten
jetzt gibt es ja viele Reaktionen wir
kommen gleich noch mal auf die Leute die
eben drin sitzen aber viele User Fragen
eben auch hat es eigentlich irgendeine
Reaktion von James Cameron gegeben sagt
er irgendetwas dazu und wir haben dich
eben auf mehreren Fotos gesehen von
deiner Expedition Kapsel aber auch Du
zusammen mit James Cameron als Titanic
Expertin und auch sozusagen als jemand
der von der Titanic fasziniert ist da
irgendwas
also ich habe jetzt bisher noch nichts
gelesen ich glaube aber dass die im
Moment auch einfach sehr vorsichtig sind
weil es halt Spekulationen auch ist
Cameron ist ja nicht nur zum Wrack der
Titanic mehrfach getaucht sondern ist ja
auch als erster allein Taucher in einem
ganz ganz engen ein Mann U-Boot in den
Marianengraben getaucht also der hat
eine massive intensive Bindung zu diesem
Thema kehrt auch immer wieder so zu dem
untersee-themen zurück ähm und der weiß
auch ganz genau welche technischen
Leistung es ist so ein Tauchboot zu
konstruieren weil eben er zusammen mit
seinem Bruder dieses
mariannengraben-boot konstruiert und
gebaut hat und ich glaube dass der
einfach genügend Fingerspitzengefühl hat
sich jetzt nicht zu Wort zu melden
aber die Frage an dich du kennst auch im
Grunde genommen zwei Menschen der fünf
die in dieser Zeiten in diesem Tauchboot
sind erklär einfach mal ein bisschen den
Hintergrund werden von Johannes haben
wir ja schon mitbekommen wer aber auch
Passagiere oder sozusagen zahlende Gäste
an Bord sind aber erklär einfach mal wer
steuert dieses Tauchboot fährt das
automatisch und sind das wirklich nur
fünf in Anführungsstrichen Touristen die
Zahlen oder steuert jemand das Boot ist
da jemand Copilot erklärt jemand was da
unten passiert wie sieht das aus also
die Kapazität in der Kapsel sind fünf
Personen und die sind jetzt bei den
Titanic Tauchgängen im Prinzip so
aufgeteilt gewesen dass man einen
Piloten hat das ist in dem Fall wohl
auch der Chefpilot des Unternehmens ist
Dr Rush der ist auch gleichzeitig der
Firmenchef der CEO und dazu setzen Sie
einen Titanic Experten sage ich jetzt
mal der wenn man unten am Wrack ist und
alles schön ist dann auch einfach mal
erklären kann was man da sieht oder
vielleicht auch wie sich das verändert
hat weil die Tauchfahrten zum brat
gibt's ja nun auch schon seit mehreren
Jahrzehnten also das heißt zwei dieser
fünf Leute gehören im Prinzip zur
Besatzung einmal der Pilot und dann in
dem Fall war der Experten
genau Jolie das ist ein absoluter
Titanic Veteran der hat also schon 30 35
Tauchgänge zur Titanic mit verschiedenen
Expeditionen mit verschiedenen
tauchkapseln hinter sich und war im
Prinzip jetzt auch die letzten drei
Expeditionen immer der Chef Experte von
Ocean Gate und dann hat man drei Plätze
frei in dem Fall eben für
bezahlte Passagiere Ocean Gate selber
hat immer gesagt wir machen keine
touristische Rundreise sondern wir sind
eine wissenschaftliche Expedition und
wir haben quasi Sponsoren die mit ihrem
Beitrag die Expedition erst möglich
machen und die dann aber auch als
vollwertiges Crewmitglied da mit drin
sitzen und auch nicht eine Standardtour
am Wrack abgespult bekommen sondern die
haben auch jedes mal andere Stellen am
Brack untersucht haben auch für die
Wissenschaft teilweise Proben genommen
Fotos gemacht und so weiter also das
heißt der Pilot der Experte und dazu
fünf Passagiere zahlen die Gäste
Touristen wie man es jetzt eben nennen
will und die sitzen in zwei Reihen im
Prinzip wobei es jetzt keine festen
Sitze gibt sondern es einfach einen
Boden und man setzt sich dann halt mal
wieder um und dann kann man mal durch
dieses Schau Guckloch vorne kann man
rausschauen man kann aber auch wenn man
weiter hinten sitzt sehr viel sehen weil
es gibt an der Kamera auch an der an dem
an dem an dem Tauchboot auch einige
Kameras montiert und als Live Feed die
Bilder von dieser Kamera kann man also
auch im Tauchboot über iPads über
Monitore quasi immer in alle Richtungen
um sich herum anschauen also das heißt
man sitzt drin und kann zum einen
wirklich direkt physisch durch das
Guckloch rausgucken oder auf die
Monitore gucken und schauen was die
Kameras gerade alles machen das ist so
die Standardbesetzung wenn alles gut
läuft also du hast es selbst erlebt das
ist faszinierend wird aus deinen Worten
deutlich und es zieht einen eben magisch
in die Tiefe wir wissen eben dass der
der Harding der hat selbst noch am
Wochenende geschrieben ein proud to
finally umsonst hat ein part of the
mission also der milliardär-harding ist
eben auch mit wohl an Bord gewesen oder
ist mit an Bord und eben johannes hat es
in seinem Stück schon gehabt ein British
pakistanischer Geschäftsmann mit seinem
Sohn also alle hat es eben in die Tiefe
gezogen die Faszination für die Titanic
du hast aber ja eben auch den Experten
Mr Titanic sozusagen angesprochen
paul-arina jolé und er dieser frühere
französische marinetaucher hat mal in
einem Interview gesagt when your in very
deep water wenn man also in sehr sehr
sehr tiefen Gewässer ist dann ist man
tot bevor man überhaupt begreift das
etwas eben falsch läuft insofern ist es
kein Problem hat er gesagt was ist dir
denn durch den Kopf gegangen oder wie
ist denn dieses Risiko wenn man man geht
ja man wenn man da runter geht hat man
nicht Angst dass die Nieten irgendwann
platzen wegen dieses enormen Drucks
Adrian Herzberger fragt auf Youtube wie
hoch ist denn der Druck der Boden da
unten werden die nicht zerquetscht wenn
das Tauchboot weiter sinkt was ist dir
denn durch den Kopf damals gegangen also
das Tauchboot ist ja für eine gewisse
Tiefe ausgelegt und das ist jetzt bei
diesem Tauchboot 4000 Meter und wenn die
Titanic erreicht ist wenn der Boden
irgendwo im Bereich der Titanic erreicht
ist ist man da noch nicht runter also
grundsätzlich war dieses Tauchboot schon
für diese tiefe gedacht wenn man jetzt
irgendwo anders am Marianengraben tiefer
geht ja dann könnte es irgendwann mal
eng werden
ich fand es eigentlich habe dann auch
damals recherchiert und fand es
eigentlich fast tröstlich der Gedanke
dass wenn es jetzt wirklich so weit käme
dass es einen Riss in der Außenhülle
gibt oder irgendwas wirklich so schief
geht das kriegst du gar nicht mehr mit
also wenn es einen Riss gäbe dann wäre
der Wasserdruck da unten so stark dass
das Wasser mit Überschallgeschwindigkeit
durch diesen Riss durchgeht also da
würde man also das ist wie Licht
ausschalten da würde man nichts mehr
mitkriegen du weißt gar nicht dass du
ein Problem hast und es ist schon vorbei
das ist die gruselig aber irgendwie ja
auch dann für mich war das irgendwie
beruhigend zu wissen dass es wenn dann
schnell geht das ist aber natürlich nur
das eine Szenario das andere Szenario
was man über die Jahre wo man immer so
ein bisschen Angst hatte ist dass man
mit diesen Tauchbooten die ja unten auch
sowieso Kufen haben vielleicht am Wrack
an irgendeinem verbogenen Metallteil
einfach mal hängen bleibt und nicht mehr
wegkommt und der Druckkörper ist intakt
und dann sitzt man da unten fest und
muss einfach abwarten ob noch was geht
oder nicht und das ist sicherlich eine
extrem belastende Situation der ich auch
nicht ausgesetzt sein möchte
also das ist das während der Tat
natürlich eine gruselige Vorstellung
wenn dieses Boot einfach irgendwie
hängen bleibt und nicht mehr
manövrührfähig ist es ist wirklich ganz
schwer glaube ich Brigitte sich
vorzustellen was in den Köpfen der
Menschen da vorgeht sich da hinein zu
versetzen deshalb die persönliche Frage
eben an dich wenn du am Sonntag erfahren
hast dass dieses Boot verschollen ist
mit diesen fünf Menschen zwei davon
kennst du
was geht dir dadurch den Kopf läuft
einem da kalt den Rücken runter
ja ich gebe zu dass ich da auch so ein
bisschen ablecke und reflektiere wir
Journalisten lenken uns ab indem wir
einfach wie die Besessenen weiter
recherchieren also ich habe jetzt
einfach seit Sonntag abend jeden Fitzel
Informationen den man online und über
Agenturen und überquellen die ich sonst
noch so habe ich aufgesogen und versucht
zu lesen und immer gehofft dass der
nächste Artikel Informationen gute
Informationen mit sich bringt
das ist schwierig also eben umso mehr
als ich den den PH ganz gut kenn und ich
kenne auch den den Piloten den stockten
Rush mit dem hatte ich auch schon
mehrere Interviews und das man mag sich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen und
verdrängt so ein bisschen aber wenn man
wirklich mal ein paar Minuten deutlich
darüber nachdenkt klar da wird mir echt
Angst um bange und ich hoffe immer noch
dass es das freundlichste aller
Szenarien ist das tatsächlich der
Druckkörper intakt ist sie ist irgendwie
geschafft haben aus dieser Tiefe in der
sie bereits gewesen sein müssen
zumindest in die Hunderter Bereiche
wieder hochzukommen also dass man sagt
die sind 100 Meter unter der
Wasseroberfläche oder sie sind ganz hoch
gekommen und wir müssen sie nur noch
finden das sind tatsächlich die
Szenarien wo man einfach sagt das hätte
momentan die beste Prognose
wir wollen aber eben weil du ja selber
auch sagst du hast jetzt wirklich alles
gelesen du bist vielleicht die beste
informierteste Person wir wollen dein
technisches nur hau eben weiter nutzen
weil du so viele Fragen gibt Robert
Flüge fragt über Youtube gibt es denn
ein zweites baugleiches oder ähnliches
Tauchboot das an dieses Wrack rankommen
könnte also insofern helfen könnte nur
mal als Frage diese Firma Ocean Gate
Expedition hat noch zwei weitere Boote
aber könnten die denn diese gleiche
Tiefe schaffen könnten die irgendwie
helfen nein also die anderen um U-Boote
die Ocean Gate gebaut hat die sind für
viel flachere Gewässer also flaches
relativ da reden wir dann über 1000
Meter Tiefe 2000 Meter Tiefe es gibt
weltweit wenn wir jetzt über bemannte
U-Boote reden gibt es ganz wenige die
das können die Franzosen haben eins die
Amerikaner haben Alvin haben wir ja
vorhin auch gesehen in Japan gibt es
noch eins die Russen hatten mal zwei die
momentan aber glaube ich nicht mehr im
Einsatz und zertifiziert sind eins davon
ist zwischen inzwischen steht in einem
Museum in Kaliningrad so weit ich da den
letzten Stand habe und die würden mir an
der Stelle wo sie jetzt sind ja auch
erstmal nichts bringen also wenn ich
jetzt einen ein perfekt für diese
Rettungsaktion geeignet ist tauch-u-boot
hat das in weiß ich nicht den Gewässern
vor Florida ist oder das noch schlimmer
ist im Pazifik ist bis ich das geraden
habe bis ich das irgendwohin geschafft
habe sie sind vermutlich alle zu groß um
sie sinnvollerweise mit dem
Frachtflugzeug hinzubringen manche
brauchen auch
Unterstützung von einem Mutterschiff das
abgestimmt sein muss die kann man nicht
einfach irgendwo auf dem schiffkutter
hinten drauf schmeißen und dann von dort
aus ins Wasser bringen also die gibt es
aber das ist eine sehr theoretische
Möglichkeit
unbemannte Drohnen also irgendwelche
Gefährte Fahrzeuge unbemannt eben die
kurzfristig in die Tiefe könnten es gibt
ferngesteuerte Tauchroboter da ist jetzt
gerade auch einer unterwegs die das
französische meeresforschungsinstitut
hatte tatsächlich zufällig in nicht
allzu weiterentfernung einen
Expeditionsschiff das genauso so eine
ferngesteuerten Tauchroboter an Bord hat
die rechnen damit dass sie im Laufe des
Mittwochs an der Unfallstelle
möglicherweise ankommen
und dann ist aber halt auch wieder die
Frage wie geht man vor wie sucht man da
weil anders als dieses Flugzeug das aus
der Luft sehr schnell große Flächen
abscannen kann sind diese Tauchroboter
weitestgehend auf optische Erkennung
angewiesen also man kann gucken was vor
den Kameras ist vielleicht hat es noch
ein so nah an Bord das ist aber alles
eine sehr kurzfristige Strecke also wenn
ich mit diesem Solar 100 200 Meter um
mich herum ausleuchten kann sozusagen
digital dann ist der Boden da unten auch
wenn man davon ausgeht dass sie irgendwo
im Großraum dieses Wracks liegen immer
noch sehr groß sind was bisher glaube
ich noch gar nicht besprochen wurde es
ist jetzt nicht so dass man an einem
fixen Punkt über dem Wrack sich quasi
nach unten fallen lässt und dann genau
wie so eine Stricknadel nach unten Punkt
genau ankommt sondern auf dieser
Wassersäule da gibt es sowas wie Wetter
da gibt es Strömungen die sind auch
immer wieder anders das heißt man weiß
gar nicht wenn man sich sozusagen
heißt wenn man in die Tiefe sinkt weiß
man gar nicht mit welcher Abweichung man
unten ankommt und dann im Umkehrschluss
sollte es zum Beispiel eine Notaufstieg
oder eine notaufstiegsversuch gegeben
haben ist es auch nicht genau im 90 Grad
Winkel über dem letzten Punkt den man
von dieser Position hat sondern das kann
auch
hunderte Meter abweichen vielleicht auch
mehrere Kilometer je nachdem wie die
Strömungen da gerade sozusagen irgendwie
seitlich einwirken also das ist eine
eine riesen Fläche bzw ein riesen Kubus
den man jetzt im Prinzip durchsuchen
müsste und deswegen dieser Tauchroboter
der hätte auch extreme Zeitdruck dann da
was zu finden also damit hast du
hervorragend die Frage beantwortet von
Alexander Hahne der eben über dieses
französische Spezialfahrzeug etwas
wissen wollte und just Flow passend hat
gefragt über Youtube ob es denn
unerwartete unter Wasserströmungen
gegeben haben könnte die dann eben dazu
führen dass die Zeit in erwartet weit
weg von der Location ist es sind nicht
unerwartete Wasserströmungen sondern du
sagst es gibt diese Wasserströmungen
insofern ist das eben absolut
realistisch dass das so passiert Ulrich
Beckmann du ich habe es ja schon gesagt
beschäftigt sich mit der Titanic mit der
ganzen Geschichte dem Finden des Wracks
etc schon seit Ewigkeiten seit langem
Jahren Ulrich Beckmann fragt war es den
ursprünglich im Jahre 1995
als man das Wrack der Titanic zum ersten
Mal überhaupt georte gefunden hat nicht
angedacht die Koordinaten des Titanic
Wracks geheim zu halten um eben
Touristen von so etwas abzuhalten
ja die Koordinaten waren 1985 erstmal
nicht zur Veröffentlichung vorgesehen
aber das hat keine 24 Stunden gedauert
denn die Koordinaten sind damals schon
per Funk an nach Kanada gegangen also
die haben
Bildmaterial zusammengeschnitten
bereitgestellt und die sollten dann
sozusagen um die Sensation der
weltkunden zu tun sind die dann ein
Stück weit Richtung Kanada Gefahren ein
Helikopter kam ihnen entgegen hat diese
sende Bänder das war ja damals alles
noch nicht digital entgegengenommen und
in dieser allerersten Informationen
diesen ersten Informationspaket das nach
Kanada ging waren die Koordinaten schon
drauf weil ähm diese Unterwasserbilder
und diese Bilder von diesen Raum mit
diesen ganzen kontrollmonitoren weil man
sie da ablesen konnte also deswegen die
Katze war da schon sehr früh aus dem
Sack
nichtsdestotrotz also wirklich die
genaue Koordinate auf die Minute auf die
Sekunde also sehr präzise die war lange
nicht bekannt und die ist dann erst auch
wirklich sozusagen gelegt worden im
Vorfeld von einem IMAX-Film den die
russischen Tauchboote 1993 also das ist
Veröffentlichungsjahr dann gemacht haben
da musste man sich sozusagen einen
Insider von einer früheren Expedition
abwerten der die Koordinaten kannte
damit das russische
meeresforschungsinstitut und die Piloten
da dann die genaue Koordinaten hatten
aber ist die Katze ist aus dem Sack das
macht dann auch keinen Unterschied mehr
ob dann später Touristen das finden
wollten oder nicht wenn die Anbieter von
solchen tauchkapseln die Koordinaten
haben dann macht er keinen Unterschied
ob ich jetzt Wissenschaftler mitnehme
oder ob ich zum Beispiel zahlende
Touristen mitnehmen
nun ist es so Brigitte also die
Koordinaten sind länger bekannt es hat
schon viele Tauchgänge dahin gegeben du
bist 1998 eben auf eine Expedition der
hingetaucht und bist sicher wieder
zurückgekommen und jetzt ist eben das
bedauerliche das eben die Titan mit fünf
Menschen an Bord eben bisher nicht
gefunden nicht aufgetaucht ist und die
Suche die dramatische suche eben weiter
läuft wir haben mehrere Kommentare Murat
als Beispiel schreibt eben hoffentlich
werden sie bald gerettet und du hast es
selber beschrieben was in dir vorgeht
wenn man Leute kennt wenn man selbst da
unten war wie sehr man eben hofft dass
du sagst es ist eben das beste Szenario
Eintritt sie eben doch weiter oben sind
und sie sozusagen nur noch an einer
geringeren Tiefe oder vielleicht sogar
an der Wasseroberfläche gefunden werden
müssen dann wollen wir das Hoffen und
danken dir aber ganz herzlich Brigitte
für all die Information deine
Schilderung deine Eindrücke die doch
sehr ja uns nahe gebracht hat welche
Faszination da drin steckt aber eben
auch wie viel
darauf achten ist wie das Risiko ist
Brigitte vielen vielen Dank für deine
Expertise für deine Schilderungen vielen
Dank und Grüße nach München tschüss
tschüss ja das war unser Livestream zur
Suche nach dem Titanic Tauchboot das
seit Sonntag vermisst wird wir haben es
gesagt die Zeit wird knapp Brigitte hat
es auch noch mal beschrieben was eben
das Wichtige ist nicht irgendwie
Wasservorräte sondern eben die Luft der
Sauerstoff der geht zu Neige und das
dramatische ist eben dass auch die
Menschen selbst wenn die Kapsel an der
Oberfläche ist sie nicht selbst öffnen
können und frische Luft schnappen können
sie muss gefunden werden sie muss
gefunden werden und nur dann können
diese fünf Menschen überleben wir halten
sie im ZDF auf ZDF heute in unseren
Social Media Kanälen weiter auf dem
Laufenden und sagen jetzt an dieser
Stelle vielen Dank für Ihre Kommentare
Fragen und das Interesse vielen Dank
tschüss
[Musik]